An Easter egg over 40 years in the making
— "Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny"
slipped in one reference that made fans
hurt almost everywhere. Spoilers ahead!
In a conclusion as epic as “The Dial
of Destiny,” it was inevitable that
Dr. Jones's last great adventure would be
filled with callbacks. But director James
Mangold saves the best hat tip for the
end when we get a reunion between Indy
and a love he’d thought he’d lost. Well,
there’s no time like the present, eh, Indy?
After returning from a trip of over two thousand
years in the past, Indy wakes from his near-fatal
gunshot wound back in his apartment with no idea
of how he got there. Turns out, after a swift hit
to the face from his darling goddaughter, Helena,
they, along with Teddy and a German pilot we never
see again, escaped the past, where Indy survived
his injuries thanks to the miracle of modern
medicine. There’s still one surprise left for the
old time traveler, though. Minutes after waking
up, he comes face to face with his estranged
wife, Marion, played as always by Karen Allen.
When the two are left to hash it out, it isn’t
long before they kiss and make up exactly how they
did 42 years earlier. For franchise fans, it’ll no
doubt get you in the feels here…and here…and here.
Proving that they still have chemistry even
after all these years, Marion and Indy’s
moment is the perfect send-off the franchise
needed, taking things full circle and showing
that even through grief, these two were meant
for each other. Having both mourned the loss
of their son Mutt in different ways, Marion
reveals she still hurts from what’s happened
and the fact they’ve been distant from one
another. Indy asks her where it doesn’t hurt,
and he plants a kiss everywhere she points. It’s
a heartfelt role reversal from a moment that’s not
just a staple in the franchise but a true piece
of cinema history in “Raiders of the Lost Ark.”
During the first adventure of Indiana Jones,
Marion is tending to Indy’s wounds.
After being asked where it doesn’t hurt,
they finally show affection for each other,
with Marion kissing Indy before he drifts off.
"Jones. Jooones."
It’s easily one of their best moments together,
so seeing it replicated in "Dial
of Destiny" hits just right,
rounding things off with a loving reunion
and an almost heartfelt goodbye to the great
adventurer. He got a happy ending he deserved,
but it’s one that finally sees him tending to
emotional injuries rather than the physical
ones we’ve seen him take after so many years.
While the closing moment of “The Dial of
Destiny” is a great little nod to Indy’s origins,
it also ties everything in a charming bow
as our worn-down hero gets the resolution he
needs. For most of Indy’s last great adventure,
there’s an added bit of regret to the standard
stubbornness we’ve always come to anticipate
with our beloved explorer. This isn’t just a
story about a hero past his prime, but
the regret of past mistakes he fears he
can never resolve. He even goes as far as to
accept that, quite literally, staying in the
past is the best course of action as opposed to
a present that he believes has no place for him.
Of course, that’s not the case. While he’s
helpless to change the loss of his son,
who died after joining the army against his
father’s wishes, he can still fix some things.
“The Dial of Destiny” gives Indy the chance to
be a hero in a different way and return to being
the loving husband to Marion that she’s needed,
even if he didn’t originally have it in him to
be that particular hero. The world will always
need Indiana Jones, but Marion needs him more,
and that’s the most important thing. After
all, as Marion said from the very beginning…
"I'm your g—damn partner."